you can learn a lot more from the
failures than you can from the successes
fail early fail often fail forward you
will fail your way to greatness
one success model the best what's that
belief nation it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn one of the most common
rules that successful people follow
learn from failure also if you want to
know what my self Will Smith Kobe Bryant
and others have to say about confidence
and excellence check out my to 54 series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
links to join are in the description
below if you're doing work that you
loved you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it I was excited
about taking a shot the fact that it was
so strange you start with when you want
your game to be will we make your game
most unstoppable or hard to deal with
[Music]
we talked about this often and we always
talk about the fact that you can learn a
lot more from the failures than you can
from the successes and you have to
figure out where those landmines are and
then how to best avoid those or put or
help entrepreneurs and ourselves
included figure out the clues of where
those land lines are not that you're
going to avoid all of them but it's also
when you do step on one figure it out
okay how do you recuperate how do you
balance back and you'll pick yourself up
I love this one fail early fail often
fail forward you know it's always a
little bit frustrating to me when people
have a negative relationship with
failure failure is a massive part of
being able to be successful you have to
get comfortable with failure yet you
have to actually seek failure failure is
where all of the lessons are you know
when you go to the gym and you workout
you're actually seeking failure you want
to take your muscles to the point where
you get to failure because that's where
the the adaptation is that's where
growth is successful people who fail a
lot they fail a whole lot more than they
succeed but they extract the lessons
from the failure and they use that the
the energy and they use the wisdom to
come around to the next phase of success
you got to take a shot you have to live
at the edge of your capabilities you got
to live where you're almost certain
you're gonna fail that's the reason for
a practice practice is controlled
failure you're getting to your limit
getting to your limit getting to your
limit you can't lift that you can't do
that you until you get to the point that
all of a sudden your body makes the
adjustment and then you can do it
failure actually helps you
to recognize the areas where you need to
evolve so fail early fail often fail
forward I think that the people that are
on that are discovering how to unleash
their greatness of people who have the
mental resiliency and the courage to
face failure if you will fail your way
to greatness that most people allow
their fear of failure
80% allow their fear of failure Tagle
their desire to succeed when you're
willing to fail again and again and
again when you make up your mind to
become unstoppable when you make up your
mind to become a no matter what person
then that will then give birth to a part
of yourself that you don't know right
now what was your biggest failure and
how did it change you it's a really
think hard about that failure there's
your answer
yeah well there's a ton of failures
along the way that's for sure
like I said as a support for SpaceX the
first three launches failed and we were
just barely able to scrape together
enough parts and money to do the fourth
launch that both launch had failed we
would have been dead so multiple
failures along the way I tried very hard
to get the right expertise in for for
SpaceX I tried hard to to find a great
chief engineer for the rocket but it but
the good chief engineers wouldn't join
and the bad ones well there was no no
point on hiring him
so I ended up a chief engineer at the
rocket so if I could have found somebody
better then we would have maybe had less
than three failures if you want to
succeed then you need to adjust how you
see failure failure is gonna happen if
you look at the most successful people
in the world we've studied them where in
the book they're all over the channel
they feel the most the most successful
person and you look up to these like wow
that person is so successful I can't
believe it
they have failed way more than you even
try
not everything works out most of the
series that I put out on this channel
don't work out we test constantly and
most of them never go anywhere they just
don't get enough traction there's an
experiment you failed we move on to the
next one we have failed more than most
people even try and that's why we
succeed and that's a consistent habit
around people who are winning they win
because they tried so many other things
and a certain percentage make their way
through and most people are so afraid to
fail but they don't even try and that's
the biggest failure of all they're so
afraid of it not working out but not
being the big hit but they just sit on
their idea and then they watch somebody
else make tons of money you have a huge
impact from it get it out there may not
be the biggest version of what you're
trying to do but start start small build
momentum see if you still even like this
thing or not see if you can get some
people interested in their line and
expect to fail failure is not the enemy
failure is normal failure is welcomed
right you're gonna learn from it you're
gonna build on it you're gonna make it
better if you are not feeling if you're
winning every time think about it like
if you're winning every time everything
you touch wins that means you're playing
a tiny game it means you're racing
against three-year-olds great
congratulations you won every single
race because you're running against
three-year-olds if you want to be the
best you want to have an impact you want
to make your business a success you want
to make money you want to reach people
you didn't have to race against people
who are a little more skilled and
talented you're gonna have to risk
losing you're not gonna win every race
but the good news is you don't have to
you don't have to win every race to
succeed you just have to win one you can
run a hundred races you just need to win
one and then they call you an overnight
success I think if you don't fail you're
not doing it right to be honest I think
you should be failing often but it's
important it teaches you your limits and
shows you like the limits you need to
pass but nobody ever made mistakes Mike
would be Ruby boring
yeah if you only try to succeed then
you're limiting yourself not to fail
which your failure could eventually
believe the greatest underside yeah
never be afraid of not getting it right
or failing or not getting the part or
not getting the job like it's just one
more notch in your belt but you're still
gonna wear it that's a long piece of
leather he's tons of room for more
notches nobody sees they're like 17 plus
years of work that I've done before
today where you finally stumbled upon a
video of mine my father is you know he
grew up in abject poverty
he had no running water he always talks
about how the outhouse in North Carolina
he didn't know if it was worse in the
winter or the summer and you can use
your own imagination for why that may be
and he said then he moved uptown into an
eight-foot-wide trailer because it did
have running water and plumbing and all
that good stuff and my dad really lived
the American dream
and coming from humble beginnings to
creating a global Empire because of his
vision and because of his drive and
never giving up and accepting you know
mistakes and failures and learning from
them you know I think that that is a
really big part of growth and oftentimes
people see it as setbacks and that's not
what it is you you have to learn it's a
learning opportunity you know why did it
fail what went wrong what could I have
done differently and then apply that
knowledge you know my dad also always
says intelligence is the application of
knowledge and I completely agree with
that you're sort of me really is one of
being able to rebuild and so few people
a can do it and be the ones that can and
have don't want to talk about it and so
how do you think about failure how have
you conceptualized in your mind why are
you so able to talk so openly about it
you know I did interview with Ryan Leaf
but we were talking about big failures
and his failure was even more public in
mine but the number one shameful thing
of losing everything and the most
courageous thing was to face our mothers
you know you talk about the public and
here I had I said today I'd sheriffs
lined up at my Rancho Santa Fe home and
moving trucks to take everything out
I hope you know 33 homes alone in San
Diego gone a golf courses ski mountain
so beyond my community and associates
and all of this and I was already
working for Li this is from past
transgressions I was already on my path
and journey of fulfillment but the
hardest thing was to walk through my
mom's house think tough oh I get choked
up I had to tell her that not only did I
fail her myself
but I felt it felt really really tough
so that failure to me was the toughest
part you know and so for me all the
other things were just learning
experiences but I had to get over the
shame of that you know here they took my
mom's house my dream of getting rich was
only to buy my mom a house in a car
that's you know I grew up with nothing
six kids single mom so for me mm-hm
to make it back I was already on that
journey and I felt as if I could stay in
a place of giving and faith and and I
mean faith in myself and faith in the
universe faith and others of service
that everything would come back to me
and it did so often you don't move
forward because you're keeping such
score from what didn't work in the past
you are holding yourself hostage to 1997
to 2005 you're holding yourself hostage
in love to that past relationship that
didn't work or you're holding yourself
in hostage in business to the money that
you may have thought you wasted or the
deal that went bad and so one of the
ways that I give myself permission for
two levels permission to have lived a
life that has some beautiful experiences
and some really tangy lessons I mean
they're spicy they hurt they're painful
when I give myself permission to have
had that I also give myself permission
to keep leaping give myself permission
to keep dreaming give myself permission
to keep learning how to get it right
learning how to love the unlovable
forgive what seems to be the
unforgivable to leap again even while I
still have a bandage on my chin from the
time I fell I still get to leave someone
invite you if you fall fall catch your
breath
put a bandage on it whether you fail
financially you fail physically with
health and wellness you felt spiritually
you fell emotionally you felt in a
relationship okay a part of flying is
understanding what the distinction
between flying and falling and the only
way you understand the distinction is
that you experience full life when you
experience full life it's like this life
isn't just flat line is not just like
this you make your Heights feel better
because you understand this was a
failure and and what I mean by a
failures this taught me a lesson this
stung this every single failure has a
lesson in it to me a failure is a lesson
wrapped in some sticky icky paper that
stung that hurt and so give yourself
permission give yourself permission to
play big to be nervous to fall down to
sit down for a minute just don't take up
real estate in the sitting down don't
take up real estate in the analyzing
don't take don't take up real estate in
the preparation you've been getting
prepared for a long time for something
trust that you'll either fly if you leap
right now or your fall if you leak right
now and if you fly you'll understand
what soaring feels like and if you fall
you'll understand what getting up feels
like either way you're okay
that's how I play big with my knees
knocking and that's how I play big even
when there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time I did something like this and it
didn't quite work out and I still play
big because I gave myself I give myself
I constantly give myself permission to
totally win and soar are totally falling
it up
and that way was nothing to truly be
afraid of remember this is a dialogue
not a monologue which means we're in a
dynamic conversation versus me just
entertaining you in the middle of 2009
he was the software engineer that no one
wanted to hire he had 12 years of
experience at Yahoo but he was rejected
by Facebook and then rejected by Twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great CV but he decided to team up with
one of his alumni members at Yahoo and
started to create an app and focus on
the startup space in five years time he
sold that out for 19 billion dollars to
Facebook believe it or not that was
Brian Acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from Facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people I
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by Twitter he
responded by saying worked out it was
quite a long commute
it's so interesting to see that someone
rejected from two of the top internet
companies actually responded with humor
and actually responded with positivity
this lady was diagnosed with clinical
depression her marriage had failed and
she was jobless with a dependent child
she was on a four-hour delay train
journey from Manchester to London when
she came up with this idea and she
started to write this book about this
wizard and as she started writing she
then finished her manuscript to get the
12 publishers and was rejected by all of
12 believe it or not that's JK Rowling
this man watched his first company
crumble he was a Harvard University
dropout and his first company's demo
didn't even work he went on to build
Microsoft his name's Bill Gates
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we need to be
ready and build ourselves up for the
next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle we just accept what we
thought was our goal what we thought we
were chasing but actually I've noticed
that when you don't get that later down
the line you look back and you reflect
and realize that what you've gained is
so much greater failures are only
failures when we don't learn from them
because when we learn from them they
become lessons and we actually extract a
lay all of these teachings and actually
get more insight into how we can improve
the way we work and how we can actually
drive with a different energy the
challenge we have is that we only talk
about people's failures when they
succeed and that's why they become this
taboo or we feel like their failures
never happened we need to share these
stories earlier we need to bring out
these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps
and that's why Steve Jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards
now I've got a really special bonus cut
from Aubrey Marcus on how to grow
through failure that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go
question number one what are you not
doing because you're afraid of failing
number two what's the worst-case
scenario if your idea doesn't work and
number three how are you planning for it
so you can have the courage to step
forward
absolutely everything I tried and like
what what did you try the didn't work
out literally everything I mean I tried
gold mining I tried some variety of
different online retail from sex toys to
skincare to I tried oil and gas I tried
like oil and gas like trading sytem
know I was like invest like investor
relations you know like trying to
convince people to go bet on some
Wildcat oil well in the middle of
nowhere that never works you know and
I'd get some stock options like this
one's gonna hit never hit you know thing
but now looking back I'm grateful
because I literally failed at everything
that wasn't directly going to serve my
purpose and all of those failures all
the lessons gave me the strength to be
able to hold an organization of this
magnitude that I'm holding now like the
person that I was then couldn't run on
it like I couldn't write the book that I
wrote I couldn't do the things that I'm
doing I couldn't have this conversation
now cuz my ego would get in the way and
all kinds of things I wasn't ready yet
and so the universe was like no not
ready fail fail fail and up but I was
like man I'm just I'm 30 and I'm failed
at everything you know I scratched out a
little money here and there you know I
was doing alright doing better than some
of my peers when I would go buy bottles
at the club and party like I could buy a
more expensive bottle than they could
and so everybody's like yeah I'll be
you're killin I'm like I'm not killing
it I'm like blowing it and that was that
was tough and then finally it just kind
of lined up with the the right timing
and the right idea and the right person
leading it meaning me and I was able to
come to fruition if you want to know the
eight things that you must do to avoid
failure check out the link right next to
me I think you'll enjoy the video
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you want to be successful learn
from the other people's mistakes don't
learn from the successful stories